he's still got it Willie asseco once
played for the Gabonese national team
today he uses basketball to motivate
young people a sec OHS club isn't about
training professionals the former player
is convinced that young Gabonese can
learn life lessons from the sport
discipline the team spirit in Fairplay
are important inside and outside the
court basketball also help us to to keep
all these kids out of the trouble
because if then if when they on the code
they are not doing something wrong and
we have the opportunity to talk with
them we have to opportunity to mentor
them to help them if they have project
we have the opportunity to to put woman
on on the same level than men because as
you can see they played together today
the young entrepreneur is accompanying
Junior agonda on his way home the ax
wenjun neighborhood of libreville is
where a sec Oh himself grew up that was
before he went to study in Germany a sec
Oh believes that children from poor
homes should also be able to dream big
and that their parents should support
them there is the sentence we say in
German if I mean if when shits van dang
I mean if we don't do that who else will
be the small state of Gabon is a
relatively rich country due to its oil
reserves nevertheless youth unemployment
is high that's why after earning a
degree in engineering a sec Oh returned
home to start a car service logistics
company he now has ten employees the
business is doing so well that he even
has to turn down orders Willie asseco
has truly found his place back in Gabon